monkey where are we going
[Music]
yes
so today we're gonna go buy tyka's
christmas presents we were supposed to
go yesterday but we didn't get a chance
to just because he fell asleep i ended
up driving around the city went to a
different store he woke up there we
stayed there it got really hectic
because i hate shopping
so then i'm gonna do it today oh my god
there's like this cute little bird here
i'm gonna show you
because it's so far away maybe it's a
hummingbird it's a hummingbird
what
and tyka just wanted to tell you that he
put on his seatbelt all by himself
good job all right let's go shopping
okay baby
all right so we're here and taika is
ready
so taika wrote his list this is the
people he's gonna buy for he is ready
you ready to rock
let's go
okay so who are you getting this for
a nominee
for jay why oh
he likes dogs she likes skulls oh you're
dropping stuff
that's for who
you already got this for jayden what is
this one i don't know you dropped it put
it back you didn't get it for anybody
no
it fell it was right here
you need to get one for so that's for
who um
guy
[Music]
she likes babies yeah oh okay
[Music]
[Music]
all right so here it is for his
classmates
we got all of this
this is pretty cool stuff
i wonder what the quality is like but
hey
not complaining so he got all his
christmas shopping done i can't wait for
you guys to see what he got his dad it's
so funny
[Applause]
[Music]
oh don't let it go under the table
as you can see we are back home
tech is already playing with his drone
okay go why don't you squash
oh my god that almost went straight to
your face
oh no it probably needs more battery you
need to charge it
okay so i wanted to show you what we got
from 99 cent store which is ironic
because i just realized it's not 99
cents anymore i don't know why they
called it 99 cents store maybe they
changed the name and i just keep calling
it the 9910 stuff but some of these
items were like 10 bucks 12 bucks 13
bucks anyway so this is what he picked
up
he picked up a lot of these
i got these actually for his little
classmates for jiu jitsu and his actual
school
he picked these up for
all of his cousins
this one's funny because this is for me
and then that's for papa and i was like
are you sure that's all you want to get
he goes yep and i'm like okay so that's
for us
so these are all the presents look this
is what i'm talking about i didn't know
that
that's three books
yeah so this is
all the presents that taika picked up
now he has to wrap them these are some
of the
wrapping papers that he picked
i'm excited to see how he's gonna wrap
this but he's got it you got it dude not
sure if we'll try to tackle this today
or another day
because i like wrapping presents and
putting them under a tree and right now
we don't have a tree yet like we have
that guy
but i don't consider this guy a tree i
consider this guy decoration and i want
a tree right here so
oh my god baby
and i finally have to put that stuff up
anyway so i don't know why he keeps
slapping his butt like that he's so
weird
um
so yeah that's the 99 cent store and
then we went to trader joe's i picked
this up for all his little teachers i
thought it was just really cool
just snacks it's nicely wrapped
looks really pretty
and we're done so he has about six
different teachers that he goes to
and then we just picked up
some snacks this is what i got some of
these i've tried some of these i haven't
so i'm excited like this i haven't this
i haven't i think i've done this i want
to add chicken to it
this is some risotto
some
ring
look danish all this stuff this i've had
the banana ones i've never had these so
i'm excited to try these
and this is where the healthy stuff is
just these two oh this
that's about it that's all the healthy
stuff i bought everything else
is yummy for my tummy
so that's it
so we're ready for
house cleanup because today is sunday
which means
tomorrow is monday and i like prepping
everything cleaning everything out
getting the laundry ready
putting everything away just organizing
so that my monday i start
really good i'm not focused on anything
else other than attacking the day and
smashing on my goals so that's what the
rest of the day will look like but for
now we're going to have lunch
what should we eat
it's dinner time and taika
noodles what
oh
yeah we have a christmas countdown
calendar an advent
calendar i think it's called
yeah but taika is doing some ground
turkey we added some sesame oil some
salt and pepper some garlic some minced
garlic
has been mixing it
good job you did a great job
i washed the bowl and you washed the
bowl from mama
spatula thank you
okay so now we're going to put this
aside
and now we're going to make
the noodles
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so we're going to throw in
these noodles i think these are like
pretty decent macros 10 protein three
fat so we really like these i'm gonna
add some bok choy in there too
and it should be good right now taika is
waiting for the water to boil and make
me really nervous don't touch anything
on the middle okay
yeah there are little bubbles
yeah but we need big
roaring angry bubbles
[Applause]
yeah we need angry grown-up bubbles
yeah
yeah hey can you tell everybody what
happened to your nose right here i i got
it from the drought
what happened
the drone was going
and it was spinning and i told you be
careful and it hit you in the nose
you look you look like you got in a
fight and you beat the other guy up so
you look kind of cool
not yet but it's getting there don't do
that
it's getting there
your add is getting the best of you i
can see it but we're working it out
where
almost it's close really close
dinner is served i put the ground turkey
i put noodles and a bok choy
good job
you made dinner tonight dude
you're gonna eat now
okay we'll try it together
okay
oh thank you i don't need one thank you
so much
your mom is drinking
a white claw like a good wall or like a
good
woman
you got the white milkies
okay monkey
moment of truth get close to the bowl
please oh so hot okay blow it
run away from it okay we'll be right
back
[Music]
do you like it
are you sure
you like the dinner you made
okay
if one is really yucky
and five is really good what number is
it
six oh
it's a six
good job dude you made dinner today
thank you so much that's hungry noodles
in there yeah there's a hundred noodles
in there for sure okay enjoy your dinner
dude
and then i dumped the soda by myself
baby okay baby good job he really did
and he didn't spill it he was trying to
show me that
he could do it without spilling it and
i'm so proud of him good job dude
you happy
bob
careful dude huh at least you're loose
it's okay and then
oh so you won and i lost
yeah washed it
the chef
was beat
it's only
5 30.
what are we gonna do
probably just let him sleep for like
maybe 30 minutes or something now maybe
an hour and then i'll wake him up
because he's gonna be [ __ ] fresh
tonight we can't be having that oh we
can't be having that especially on a
sunday no no no no
all right so it is now
nine o'clock
and the house has been quiet since i
told you taika fell asleep in this last
clip
clip
um
and i just i tried waking him up so i
did wake him up i moved him from the
downstairs where you guys saw him to the
upstairs and he knocked out and he never
woke up again wait that sounds really
wrong uh he stayed sleeping that's the
right english i wanted to use
um
yeah
and i just can't help but think
[ __ ] what is he gonna wake up
because i'm like
i would love to get eight hours of sleep
but i have a feeling he's gonna wake up
at like four or five in the morning so
i'm like [ __ ] i'm wrapping everything up
pretty happy with how
the place looks right now because
everything's clean and in order let me
see if i can show you from the beer
this is the entrance
okay
and then that's the living room
i haven't fluffed my freaking pillows
dude
look at that all the dishes are washed i
even emptied out my dish rack
cleaned my stove
i vacuumed the carpet
not up here but down there
um i did all my laundry well i have two
more loads but these are like really
small loads
everything's clean
oh god forget it i have to i saved these
till the very end because i'm just like
i'm not gonna deal with it i'm gonna
fold the big stuff and i'll worry about
this little
shitty [ __ ] stuff later so i gotta pair
a bunch of socks now but that's nothing
i have eight minutes 17 minutes left
this is clean
no laundry
everything's put away
like i got my laundry put all of it away
in taika's room hung it up folded it
nice neat
put all my [ __ ] away oops
yes i'm ready to start my day
i'm excited i love
when i just get down to it and the
entire time i'm [ __ ] complaining
don't i don't want to sound like i'm a
righteous ass [ __ ] like the entire time
i'm like okay
all right geo you've done enough we can
stop here
and then the other voice in my head goes
ah shut up you whiny [ __ ] keep going
i'm like oh you're so bright and then
again literally like 10 minutes late
i'll be like okay okay we're done that's
enough
you can stop here we'll do the rest
tomorrow and i'm like ah you [ __ ]
whiny [ __ ] shut up keep going and it's
literally like that
until i finish the tasks the only thing
that's here is just papa stuff because
he just organizes his own [ __ ] i'll fold
it for him
but he knows where it goes
and then i just washed his
transparent
blanket that he's had
for like more than half of his life
and i laid it out here because i know he
misses it we transitioned into different
uh
what is it covers i have my duvet cover
and then he has like a really thin one
that he uses but i feel like
this one although it's colder warms his
heart whereas this one warms his body a
little too much and i feel like he
thinks about this blanket
every night like when he puts this one
on i feel like he's like he feels like
he's cheating on this one so
i love how i just created this entire
narrative for bart but that's what my
heart feels so i just kind of i washed
it and i left it there for him to see
so that he could make the decision
and choose to be faithful or not and i'm
just kidding but yeah he can choose
which one he wants is he with i just
kind of felt bad that i'm like ugh
bought him anyone and he wants to be
polite so
let's see what he goes with i'll keep
you guys updated
but yeah
i feel good
i feel like now i can take a shower
wash away my day
and then tomorrow's gonna be a good ass
day
and on that note i hope you have a good
ass day today tomorrow
the day after that i'm so grateful to
have you here i appreciate you guys so
much
love you see you guys tomorrow